over the past several years the medical
field has been it would appear on a
mission to destroy its own credibility
and that process was essentially
completed when every Major Medical
Institution in the Western World decided
to wholeheartedly endorse and in many
cases actively engage in the castration
and sterilization of gender confused
children the moment that the medical
industry as a whole over the objection
of a sane minority declared that
actually biological sex doesn't exist
and that actually turns out men can have
babies uh the game was over you know
that was it the entire industry had been
ideologically captured and now it has
less scientific credibility than your
local psychic or tarot card reader or
whoever but that was not the end of the
story because things only got worse from
there the medical field cannot kill its
own credibility twice but it can dig up
the rotting corpse of its credibility
light the corpse on fire and then toss
it into the deepest depths of the sea
and that seems to be its plan now so
that brings us to the war on so-called
fat phobia which we've talked about many
times on the show and we know that
plus-sized Tik Tok influencers and
others in that vein have been on a
crusade against the imaginary concept of
fat phobia for a while now but
increasingly um doctors who might also
be Tik Tok influencers many of them are
are joining the fight uh to defend
morbid obesity Libs of Tik Tok alerts us
to one of these doctors Dr Nicole uh van
graning has a Tik Tok account with
nearly 50,000 followers where she often
discusses the the dangers of fat phobia
not the dangers of obesity but the
dangers of fat phobia and in fact she
says that Tik Tok helped to open her
eyes to this problem her medical
textbooks may tell her that obesity is
bad but Tik Tok says that it isn't and
she like so many other medical
professionals is siding with Tik tock on
this one so uh
watch I am tired all the time and
something is wrong and he said you just
need to lose some weight one of the
things I've learned as a doctor on Tik
Tok is how many people are going going
to the doctor and just being told to
lose weight now I have always known
trust me that weight can be a source of
Shame and stigma and something that
actually stops people from going to the
doctor because they want to go get help
with their problems but they don't want
to be weighed they don't want to get a
lecture on how they need to lose weight
especially when they're things that have
nothing to do with their weight and
people want to avoid that lecture on
weight loss when they just want help
with their nausea or something I think
learning from all of you creators and
commenters how big of a problem this is
has really made an impression on me and
quite frankly has changed my practice so
I actually ask patients if it is okay to
talk about weight if they don't want to
be weighted at an appointment that is
okay we actually are changing our
electronic health record to make it so
weight isn't even printed out on their
discharge paperwork if they don't want
to see it because this is crazy you
should be able to go to a doctor for a
legitimate Health concern and not have
it blamed on your weight this is not
okay well that's good yeah let's let's
not put the weight on their health
records you know uh because right
increasingly we want to remove all
actual physical information about people
from their health right because you
don't want to put weight on there
because I might offend them uh obviously
you don't want to put their biological
sex on there because I might offend them
and uh you don't want to put their
height on there because a lot of people
are self-conscious about that and you
know it's basically so everyone's health
record just just says person and and
that's that's the entire record is just
that this is a this is some but even
that might be because that that's
limiting too so it's just we're all
according to our health records we're
all just like these a amorphous kind of
uh vague Blobs of U nondescript matter
that's that's what that's what our
health records will will say about us
now first of all um I may not be a
doctor myself but I'm pretty sure that
if you are struggling with nausea your
weight could have everything to do with
it in fact pretty much any ailment
involving your stomach or your digestive
digestive tract can be caused or
exacerbated by obesity also any ailment
involving your internal organs or your
bones or your heart or any other part of
your body can be caused or exacerbated
by obesity this is one of the many basic
medical facts that this medical doctor
apparently doesn't understand or is
pretending to not understand she also
says that you know again she won't talk
about weight with her patients if they
don't want to hear about it which is
exactly the same as a dentist agreeing
to not talk about cavities or a fire
inspector agreeing to not tell you about
fire hazards or a mechanic agreeing to
ignore issues with your braking system
like the person's whole job is to
address those kinds of issues now it's
true that you know it it makes me feel
bad when the mechanic tells me that I
need new Brak pads I don't like hearing
it it makes me feel all icky and sad and
I don't I don't like it so when he when
he comes back with the break pad news I
say to myself man I wish I didn't need
new Brak pads but what I don't say is
man I wish he didn't tell me about the
break pads that's because if there is an
issue with the brake pads it's much
better that I know than I not know and
I'd much prefer a mechanic who
identifies these problems and tells me
about them than one who can't identify
them or worse can but doesn't tell me
and this logic clearly applies to
doctors too um I should say that it
applies to doctors especially but it
gets worse from Dr Nicole if you can
believe it uh let's watch this next
video from her
here's my hot take as a doctor I totally
agree it is okay to be fat we don't say
that enough but it needs to be
normalized if you are fat that is okay
it is typically not a problem that
requires immediate solving it is not an
emergency you don't have to drop
everything in the pursuit of being not
fat Aon said this other thing in a
different video that I totally agree
with as well is that it is okay to not
be healthy we act like it is this moral
failing this cardinal sin that you
deserve a Scarlet Letter if you are not
healthy and there's a name for that and
that's called healthism now don't get me
wrong in my line of work there's a lot
of people that I see that want to gain
weight lose weight take other measures
that they think will improve their
health in some way and by all means
that's what we're here for we're here to
help you with that and be supportive of
that but a good doctor will not judge
you for being fat they will not judge
you for being unhealthy they will not
judge the decisions that you made or the
decisions that were made for you which
is the much more likely scenario that
got you to the point where you are right
now we're here to help you with the
changes that you want to make and if you
are someone who wants to lose weight for
health purposes and there are certain
scenarios where losing weight can be
Health promoting we're here to help you
with that we are also here to help you
if you decide to not make any changes at
all we're still there now it's it's hard
to know where to begin except to say
that a doctor who announces it's okay to
be unhealthy should be immediately fired
and then bankrupted by malpractice
lawsuits if you are a patient of Dr
Nicole then you would be better off
getting on a plane and flying down to
Brazil and then hiking into the Amazon
to seek medical care from a tribal
Shaman in a mud hut somewhere deep in
the jungle in fact a lot better off
actually because the shaman may not have
the best remedies for your ailments but
at least he'll recognize that your
ailments are ailments he at least knows
that being unhealthy is bad and although
Amazonian Shaman have never actually
witnessed obesity firsthand we we could
be pretty certain that if they did see
it they would recognize that it's not
ideal so no matter how you slice it this
American doctor has less medical
knowledge and credibility than somebody
whose scientific understanding of the
world hasn't Advance beyond the year
3000 BC I mean that's how bad things are
now she also assures us that um being
unhealthy is not a moral failing and and
you know that could be true in certain
circumstances I mean if you have
multiple sclerosis or arthritis or brain
cancer then your illness certainly is
not your fault but many forms of
unhealthiness are in fact at least
partially a result of your moral
failings like physical unhealthiness is
one of the main immediate consequences
of moral failings in fact obesity is the
prime example you become obese by eating
too much and exercising too little in
other words you become obese through
gluttony and sloth which are not only
sins but two of the seven deadly sins
they're both bad enough to ad made the
top seven that doesn't mean that you
should wallow in your self-loathing and
guilt if you're fat quite the opposite
realizing that your obesity is indeed
your fault and is indeed a moral failing
is empowering it means that you have the
power to change it you made yourself fat
you can now make yourself unfat and this
is good news and if a patient doesn't
want to hear the good news that's all
the more reason why they should hear it
but they're not going to hear it from Dr
Nicole who isn't interested in helping
her patients be healthier instead she
wants to free them from the bonds of
what she calls healthism it's 2024 and a
lot of us are trying to get our finances
in order there's some great news for
homeowners interest rates have dropped
and are now in the fives a lot lower
than they were last year if you've been
buried in highin credit card debt now is
the time to Break Free with American
financing American financing can help
you access the cash in your home to pay
off your highin debt last year their
salary based mortgage consultants helped
customers save an average of
$854 a month it's like giving yourself a
$10,000 raise a year and that's a great
way to start the new year to say the
least and if you start today you may be
able to delay two mortgage payments but
you got to take advantage of this deal
right now call American financing today
at
866-5696 that's
866-5696 711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 nmls consumer access.org
APR for rates and the five started 6.40
6% for well-qualified buyers call 866
569 4711 for details about credit costs
and terms now it had been about three
weeks since the left invented a new ISM
word uh so we have a new one just in
time and and it's healthism but what is
healthism well she uses the term but um
the exact definition isn't isn't clear
from the context you know we know that
racism is is supposed to be when you
hate someone based on their race uh
sexism is when you hate someone based on
their sex
so is healthism when you hate someone
because they're healthy I mean the fat
acceptance crowd does tend to resent
people who lose weight and get healthy
does that make them healthist are they
Health phobic that would actually make a
little bit of sense which is how you
know that that's not what's meant by the
term so I Googled it and here's what I
found on a website called within
health.com they have a a whole article
about healthism and this is what it says
quote healthism refers to a set of
attitudes of believes that health is the
most important pursuit in life and that
it is the personal responsibility of the
individual and solely within that
person's control those who subscribe to
these beliefs view the pursuit of Health
which is often conflated with thinness
as a moral good now just a quick note
here the pursuit of health is a moral
good now it may not be the most
important pursuit in life but given that
the continuation of your life and your
ability to pursue anything at all
depends on your health it should at
least be like in your top five of
priorities and none of this should be
remotely
controversial it's especially should not
be controversial among medical
professionals but here we are uh reading
on the problem with this is that
healthism doesn't acknowledge that
Health isn't entirely within a person's
control there are also larger biological
social cultural and environmental issues
that contribute to poor health such as
genetics poverty violence trauma
environment diet culture andp
discrimination and oppression of all
kinds including ableism racism sexism
transphobia homophobia fat phobia and
weight stigma healthism is Insidious and
stigmatizing harming people living in
larger bodies as well as many other
marginalized identities fat is a term
that has been reclaimed by higher weight
individuals and fat people are subject
to weight stigma in many different
settings by many different people these
include school work health care and even
the home by family friends Healthcare
Providers teachers coaches and
colleagues fat people are often viewed
and labeled as immoral irresponsible
lacking willpower lazy weak slovenly
unmotivated undisciplined unintelligent
and so much more healthism doesn't just
harm people living in larger bodies
either it is used to maintain ableism
racism transphobia classism and
more well that's no surprise all of the
new isms and phobias they invent are
always connected to the other isms and
phobias uh so if you're guilty of one
you're automatically guilty of all the
rest along with whatever new ones they
might make up in the future that's how
this works but whether they call this
healthism or fat phobia or whatever new
buzzword they might invent tomorrow it
doesn't change the truth which is that
it is good to be healthy and it is not
good to be unhealthy a medical
professional like Dr Nicole certainly
understands that fact notice how she
herself appears to be in excellent
physical shape so she is obviously
taking care of her body but if you want
to destroy your own body she will be
there standing on the sidelines with pom
poms
cheering you on and that's because she
wants you to be fat and weak and sick
that's what all these people want for
you they wish for you a short and
mediocre life Joy Health Fitness
longevity these are the things they want
for themselves but not for
you and and speaking of Insidious it
really doesn't get more Insidious than
that and that is why Dr Nicole and every
doctor like her is today cancelled hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there